she's a different story but it's an old
story it's it's it's the George Wallace
story it's or maybe maybe she's not so
grand as George Wallace maybe it's the
less dramatic story was the the lesser
George Wallace of Georgia but it's also
part of the whole history of the United
States and conservatism with the united
states of revival now religious
historians look at united states and say
one of the things that makes it sort of
unusual is this cyclical revival
religious revival there's the the the
first Great Awakening that before the
United States is formed as a Second
Great Awakening those arguments are we
now in the midst of a third or fourth
grade awakening if it's a fourth win to
the third end but no one disputes that
periodically throughout American history
there's been these great big revivals
they these are obviously populists
religious movements and out of them you
see leaders like George Wallace the you
know the famous populist sort of left
right Governor of Alabama or before him
Huey Long again as he left is you're
right it's hard to say is populists but
he certainly both these guys in some
ways tended to sort of consolidate power
in a way that is very very comfortable
for elites that it leads to sort of
encouraged this Sarah Palin is the
latest incarnation of this and you know
I think the question with sarah palin is
not whether or not we're in this revival
moment you look I think you look at the
tea parties and you look at the schisms
within the establishment Republican
Party and the broader conservative
movement there's no doubt we're in a
revival moment the question is is Sarah
Palin going to be the one is going to be
that standard bearer does she does she
have the juice to to become a George
Wallace or to become a Barry Goldwater
or to become something that as you said
hasn't existed before and there is
potential for that too I think because
the issues over which this populist
movement gets excited are different
then they were for Wallace or wrong or
going back further Billy Sunday not in
the political sphere but as a political
religious revival lyst they're different
issues at different times it's possible
that these fringe characters who we
traditionally understood as its big
fringe but they end up sort of pushing
the establishment one way or the other I
don't see any third parties coming but
there could be a real massive shift in
what establishment means sarah palin may
not lead that but she may just ride the
crest of that wave or there maybe she
maybe she's opened the door for someone
who is a little bit of a smoother
operator
I remember a friend of mine if it was in
France or Italy I don't remember it was
sitting in a cafe and and someone comes
running down the streets yelling the
professors are coming the professors are
coming a rampaging mob of professors
which I think liberalism wants to
dismiss his extremism but I prefer you
know my favorite forgotten president
American history's James buckhannon who
and defending really robust and sharp
elbow debates as I like the noise of
democracy I like the sound of people in
the streets making noise which is what's
made it actually ironic that so many
liberals have rushed to denounce these
these tea parties these folks on the
street as somehow anti-democratic and
mob violence and so on now I don't agree
with these these these demonstrations at
all but they're doing the work of
democracy they feel that their
governments not responding to them
they're correct and I hope it doesn't
but but they're saying look we are going
to make a lot of noise and there's going
to be sharp elbows we're not going to go
out and do this civilly and say well I
disagree with you that kind of keeping
the conversation quiet that always
favors whoever's holding the power
whoever's holding the power sings civil
and quiet whoever's outside says no I'm
not going to keep things civil quiet i'm
going to i'm going to i'm going to bang
on the door and i think that's I think
we may be in this moment you know I know
we're talking about the future of
conservatism but what's interesting to
me also is I think that there's a sense
in which were wearing you know maybe
1964 or 1963 that we could be also
moving toward a period of radical
revival as disillusionment with the
Democrat Democratic Party sets in and as
a generation of folks with just no
attachments to the last great radical
revival come up and to say look I'm
pissed about this and I don't care if
fox news is going to say I'm a 60s
retread because i was born in nineteen
eighty-five so clearly i'm not and i
think that moment could be coming
I think I think they are sustainable and
when we talk about the future of
conservatism that's it I mean these
parties are so consolidated now that you
know the idea of a serious third-party
challenge is kind of ridiculous and so
on that's the future of conservatism the
Democratic and Republican parties
combined you know the max baucus
approach to health care that's the
future of conservatism a government in
the interest of a big business
essentially but so the parties are going
to stay put but that doesn't mean
politics are going to be defined by the
party there's going to be a lot of stuff
happening beyond and on the right right
now there's all this stuff happening
what I've been interested in fact is the
real incredible just sort of a kudzu a
growth of fundamentalism in the military
and that's a faction that that's
something in play that hasn't been in
play for a long time it's one thing to
have fundamentalist activists is another
thing to have fundamentalist generals
who are armed and who have decided that
the time has come to redefine their oath
to protect and defend the Constitution
work I don't think we're in danger of
any coos but AZ talked to enough senior
officers who have lost hold of that that
traditionally pretty solid subordinate
relationship between the military and
civilian structure there's no radical
movement like that on the left but there
could be and I think a lot of the
political action the political life of
America is going to start happening
outside of the parties